i gotta learn how to make the beans from
scratch and make the sope
from scratch next time they come you
know how to make it yes
oh dang girl
[Music]
hola good morning it's not morning this
afternoon but
i don't know i just felt like that was
natural to say anyway
uh today i'm actually having my mom come
over
and she is going to teach me but
technically more
casey because he's the chef of the house
how to make boso
and i'm so excited because growing up my
mom
didn't really cook very much but
whenever she would
make things it was like this kind of
stuff like
rosole sopes tostadas jaiva
like she would just make a few things
but the things that she would make they
were delicious and i was telling her i'm
like oh my gosh i really miss it the
other day i was
really craving one of her chicken
tostadas but as we were eating it like
me and casey tried making it and i'm
like
something's off something's missing and
she was like yeah you forgot all these
other ingredients and i'm like
oh my god i forgot that was in there
yeah so like we got to talking and she
was like you know what like i'm actually
going to be making pozzole i could come
over and i could teach you how to make
it i'm like yes because i absolutely
love posole like so much i freaking love
masoli and i love eating it with sour
cream which i know it's really weird
for a lot of people but i don't care
it's delicious but anyway yeah she's
heading over
i just got out of the shower and casey
actually went to go get junebe
so my mom gets to try jun b i don't
think she's had it before
in case you guys don't know jubi is this
delicious
matcha that casey and i are investors in
like there's a whole group of us that
are investors but
in dallas i'm sure you guys know this by
now but in dallas
there is also a junebe location and in
new jersey
if you're in new jersey there's a junior
location in princeton so
you can try out your own gmd if you're
near those locations
um here in la we have one westwood one
rolling heights
and casey just went to one of those to
go get some jumbie from my mama to try
it and yeah so he's getting a whole
bunch of drinks and also
some rice balls because they're so good
all right good morning guys
before i go pick up juvie i cook with
tiff and his mom i'm running
my usual hike trail right now lately for
the past month i've been religiously
hiking and running
because man pandemic
and quarantine was not nice to my body
we recently went out to hawaii
and i was looking at the footage and man
am i out of shape
so i've been busy trying to get my body
back
into its usual semi-fit
shape we'll see how it goes
i'll update you in like another month
but yeah man i'm so tired
look at this view it's beautiful but
before we continue the video i just want
to say
a huge shout out big thank you to
soundcore for sponsoring today's video
[Music]
so i've been doing a lot of hikes as i
said and uh
on my hikes i really like listening to
not music
but audiobooks and before soundcore sent
me their new life p3s
i was carrying my headphones around and
they were heavy and they weigh you down
when you're trying to run and hike
so i'm loving taking these around
they're just so portable the sound
quality is amazing
on the off chance that i'm listening to
music these earbuds have 11 millimeter
composite drivers and soundcores base up
technology
which means you really feel the bass
there's also multiple modes of active
noise cancellation
indoor outdoor and transport mode
which means you can pick the precise
amount of noise cancellation needed for
whenever you're listening to whatever
you're listening to
you also get up to seven hours of
listening time
on a single charge that's pretty amazing
and with the compact charging case
you could extend that to 35 hours i
personally haven't owned your buds in a
long time
the reason being is that i always end up
losing them
in fact i always end up losing one of
them but with the life p3s they have a
find your earbuds function
in the soundcore app so then your
earbuds would emit a high pitch
frequency
noise making it easy to locate them when
you have lost them
so the soundcore life p3 is a great and
affordable option if you're looking for
a new set of high quality earbuds check
them out in our link below all right
i gotta continue running i'm on schedule
hello
hi you guys are here well you're back
and you're here mama i said that you
went to go get jimmy
yeah introducing jimmy to your mom yes
we
are oh my goodness so which one's this
one yeah
jasmine this is strawberry matcha yeah
with milk this is peach
lemonade green tea green tea bingo
matcha
and i got a boatload of i mean not vote
i mean flight yeah yes because they're
called flight and well it's called
flight but yeah we got mentaiko spam and
egg
and salmon rice balls are you excited to
try these mom
no you're not excited to try them oh i
had
i thought you said i haven't tried them
i was like no i'm not excited yeah yeah
you haven't tried jumbie huh
i have never tried jumbie oh and now is
your time to try
i got you a mango yes she was like i
know you like ice mango
for getting much mango from mama yeah
all right mom moment of truth
wait first uh mix it oh okay
because it's already fully sealed i'm
excited i can't believe i haven't had
you try it
masha mango jumbie yeah
it's so delicious so refreshing and
so natural next i'll get you a uh one
with uh
boba oh like what is the name of this oh
you like boba
i love boba oh nice yeah we have bubba
too
she was like you guys don't serve boba i
was like i don't normally get boba in my
life yeah i never get boba
i was like oh we'll get boba next time
yeah where's the boba
i know which is delicious we should get
you some yeah i never eat
boba or get boba okay i'm going to get
my peach
isaac come get your junior
you want your uh your rice balls yes
please
oh you tilted it baby
i'm a third grader it's okay it happens
to the best of us so i got the peach
lemonade green tea usually i get matcha
because obviously we're known for matcha
it's high quality
ceremonial grade straight from japan
delicious
matcha but this time i wanted to see
what our green tea was like
so that's why i got this uh peach
lemonade one this is our summer drink so
it has
real peach pieces in here real
lemon made pieces anyway let me see
oh same thing happened to me we're twins
we're twins baby you know what happened
i was drinking through the straw right
and a peach
piece got stuck so i i blew to like blow
it
out like to unstuck it and when i did
that that's what happened mom you we had
you come over
to make mexican food but we're eating
first
because we gotta fuel up for this
educational experience
we brought all the supplies yes i bought
everything you brought the
hominy oh you even brought the masola
pinto beans ooh for the sofa i'm excited
for this yes and then the pork she's
also gonna
show us how she makes her chili or like
her salsa i've always been trying to
make mexican food in this household
and i just find like whatever i can find
on the internet and half the times i
feel like i find
very gringified recipes as tif would say
like they're like this is not i think
something's off it's like it's funny
because
they'll be it'll taste kind of like
gringoified like what he said
but then it also tastes um a little
asian like you have like your asian
saison
in there i think the safan is in the the
cooking
uh oh the pan pots and pans that i have
it's just like it's just seasoned
that way true
so she actually wanted us to get cabbage
because usually you eat both
with cabbage i have cabbage oh yeah
napa cabbage what's nappa cabbage this
one it's not the one that's in a round
no that's not the kind that we yeah
maybe let us
be okay yeah this is slime you also
bought us the caswella too right yeah
the blue one huh it's so small this was
the next biggest part we had this was
the biggest part we had oh it's not blue
what am i doing
how did i think that was blue wait don't
we have a blue one am i tripping
oh no we threw it out and started
chipping at the bottom of the
oh okay so i'm not crazy so now you can
make this is quite the upgrade
oh yeah exactly yeah thank you mom
i know right so we're going to start
with washing the
the meat very well okay
[Music]
whole onion and one of this garlic
[Music]
okay and then we're gonna put the rest
of the meat about five pound coconut
i just take the cook about it's
351 so about four
four fifty one an hour an hour
going to chopping the lettuce the
ramanos
and the onions and the lemon
and then we're gonna put this to boil
chiles california
what we want is the cheese to be very
soft
so we can blend them together in the
meantime you want me to
prepare the uh the slippers oh yeah
everybody is so busy while your foot is
ready oh sure
look at right now oh yeah what happened
so i broke it yesterday
and then i fixed it by using a tea bag
and like super glue
and i completely fixed it and so i did
my whole nails like i painted them all
but when i was in the shower it broke
again so i'm like you know what i'm just
gonna cut it
where'd you learn that technique that's
cool oh with chorizo
ah i used to before you came around
you actually made food
just guessing mom yeah just so salt
pepper
garlic man i haven't done things like
this in so long
what else would you make when i was
growing up i remember you making
java i don't remember you making
possible but i do remember eating it
during christmas time a lot yeah i used
to make it only
during christmas and then i know how to
make tamales
all right i want to learn how to make
them
last year we were trying to make tamales
remember yeah but then we never went
about to get the ingredients
we got lazy oh yeah you taught me how to
make enchiladas
have you make them since that day well i
made them in this house want to remember
yes you did it wasn't a hit
i
[Music]
smells
tried
[Music]
you look so hot right now no right me
cooking is what you would like does your
fantasy come true
oh yeah
[Music]
is this nostalgic for you in any way
it's like is there like a memory lane
thing that you're
i never helped my mom cook that's why i
don't
i never helped her like i don't i was
never in the kitchen
oh yeah when i moved out on my own is
when that's when she like taught me
some stuff some like basic simple things
i had to make rice red rice yeah
oh yeah you taught me how to do red rice
now yeah there's some how to make
enchiladas
but at home though i never i never
helped you cook
you know never learned how to cut look
at this look at what you guys are doing
now
this is awesome i always invite you to
cook and you never wanted to
learn yeah teenager you know so you put
milk inside your the beans
inside the beans just soup because
they're canned beans
so we want to make sure is that the
beans
and the milk when they mix together it
has a better flavor
to it that makes sense oh good thing we
switched over to whole milk recently
this is going to be bomb
so we just put a little chorizo i love
the way you cook
because the the way you cook is the
cooking with love method which is
no measurements yeah it's all all by
feel yeah
i love it you twisted
[Music]
i would have never guessed that milk was
the secret ingredient for beans i
know when she said milk goes like milk
what it makes sense though because it's
creamy
creamy it's kind of like mashed potatoes
like growing up i never knew mashed
potatoes had milk in it
and when i first found out about like
mashed potatoes with milk
yeah weird this is a secret method too
yeah i just push this
and then then lift it out and then this
comes out
oh let me see that i could grow my own
lettuce
she's been gardening a lot lately oh
okay great
[Music]
that looks so good i like my beans
to beat like my i guess these are called
refried fries yeah
yeah i like them to be like smooth today
is my favorite day in the kitchen
you finally have your mexican wife doing
what she was born to do just to make
mexican food
so i'm going to be frying the sofa well
it's about to be a party in here
[Music]
oh my god all these smells it's like i'm
at home
you are at home
[Music]
that's the good stuff
[Music]
watch it dissolve look
i'm such a kid and it's gonna be cooking
for another hour
what a whole another hour in half an
hour we're gonna put the chiles
california
okay so we're gonna eat now the sofas
yes
[Music]
isaac do you want queso fresco on yours
just likes it bland he doesn't like
flavor
[Music]
all righty you literally stole a bit all
right on my
mouth i was like
[Music]
you enjoy it we got our sofas here
nice and ready we are missing tomatoes
but it's okay we don't need them we're
eating the sofas while we still wait to
finish the posadas we still got about an
hour
left nice when's the last time you had
your mom's food
when i think i was a teenager dude
so this is like over 10 years for sure
wow yeah because even when i lived alone
and you were teaching me i don't think i
had your food yeah i don't think i've
had your food since i lived in your
house
like 10 ish years i was like 20 when i
lived with you
last time yeah so i moved back with her
for a little bit
when he was born that was the last time
i probably ate your food all right let's
dig in
bite of nostalgia what do you think
about grandma's puppets
made by your mom the quality of
demonstration is
far better because
i gotta learn how to make the beans from
scratch
and make the sope from scratch
with some masa yeah with the muscle
that's the next level
that would be next level next time they
come yeah
there we go you know how to make it yes
oh dang girl
[Laughter]
i had no idea you surprised me i love
that you're taking
initiative to learn so put them all in
here mom
yeah just put all of them you can also
blend it here to get us
there's a oh
[Music]
chopped garlic like how much you know
i love it enough
i wish i could say that for all my
cooking videos just like how much of
anything
enough enough of this enough of that
perfect measurement what the heck
is it plugged what the it's not uh
lined up
yeah it's not working
did it break
what it should be should be doing it
let me try plugging it out i know this
works over
houston we have a problem we can't blend
our chilis
oh no what happened
okay
we're screwed we don't have a blender
what happened i wasn't pushing hard
enough
like i was just like this it wasn't
working but look
push harder
that was weird oh it smells so good wow
oh it smells delicious yeah we're gonna
put this in here
it looks like ketchup or do you want to
push on just like that
oh i'm scared i'm scared i'm scared i'm
scared
oh the steam is burning my fingers
you did it i feel like this is a rite of
passage for you
you're doing it and you're gonna put all
this in there
smell it oh my god that smells delicious
here smell this oh my god it reminds me
of mexico
oh yeah oh yes oh yes
that's the stuff that is the stuff
all right the posole is done
careful don't burn yourself yeah they've
taught me this in
homek it's always open the lid away from
you so the same doesn't
burn you oh that looks so good
oh this one's got a lot of meat in it no
that's for you meat boy
i can't get a spoon without meat i'm
like trying to get the harmony and it's
like all meat
that's a great problem to have in my
book i know
meat boy
[Music]
now that i'm serving my bowl it's like
all on me
here we go you're happy yes i'm so happy
[Music]
i think that's it let's dig in
[Music]
i'm happy we love you all right
let's eat man today
it is
[Music]
[Music]
just a tiny bit usually in the past i
would have drenched this assault
oh that's beautiful wow
a little bit of lime juice
i'm gonna make mine just like that one
one of the things
cheers
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm glad we documented this because i'm
most definitely gonna forget how to make
it
true so how did my mom teach me how to
break this
[Music]
we're sodium conscious here sodium
a little goes a long way
oh it's too spicy
and it does need more salt
[Music]
do
you